well anyone following the news in recent
weeks has seen the extraordinary
evolution of protests in Iran what began
as anger over heavy-handed morality
policing has turned into criticism of an
entire system A system that by many
measures has also failed the economy
look at this in 2011 gross medic
domestic product that is the value of
all goods and services produced was at
600
626 billion dollars last year a mere 241
billion dollars that's partly due to
sanctions imposed by the West as a
result of Iran's nuclear program
but mismanagement is also to blame State
institutions including the Revolutionary
guard run oil and gas companies Banks
Transportation even telecommunications
firms now there are no reliable figures
but experts estimate that the elite
paramilitary forces alone control
one-third of Iran's economy at the
expense of normal people
and my colleague Don hirschfel filed
this report take a look
every tourist or business traveler
passing through the Imam Khomeini
airport in Iran's Capital Tehran
becoming an unwitting customer of the
Revolutionary guard
they're responsible for running Iran's
air and sea ports
letting them decide which Goods can
enter the country and which companies
receive them
the Revolutionary guard also runs a
wide-ranging network of companies in all
economic areas
they build streets dams Railways and
high rises
they run clinics and direct trading
companies
they also control the largest Money
Maker in Iran the oil industry they are
a strategic power that holds sway over
Iran's entire economy including
determining what companies are
successful
the private companies which they are not
belongs to them or not working with them
they cannot compete with them because if
if you want to imagine irgc has um their
own institution which the money is
belongs to them and they influence in
many other private sectors
when the private person which is not
working with them want to compete they
have not too much chance
and Iran's religious leader Ayatollah is
an economic deal maker he controls
religious taxes from Muslims from around
the world which are collected by a
charitable Foundation
billions of dollars which are reinvested
in Iran's economy
Mission which would be collaborating
with the regime so that's mean for the
some minorities for example which they
are totally under suppression from the
regime like a region in Kurdistan they
won't have a chance to receive this
money
financial support is a competitive
advantage and the deciding factor on
which companies succeed or fail
kazra Arabi leads the Iran program at
the Tony Blair Institute he joins me now
from London uh kazra what does it mean
for protesters if the Revolutionary
guard benefits most from the current
system I would imagine that dislodging
them is going to be near impossible
well I think let's begin by making it
absolutely clear what we're seeing in
Iran today is not about the economy it's
not about the US withdrawal from the
2015 nuclear agreement and it's not
about sanctions rather it's about living
under an authoritarian
misogynistic ideological regime that has
sought to impose its ideology over every
aspect of Iranian life and has
prioritized that ideology consistently
over the needs of the Iranian people
but to what extent can that regime point
to the economy and point to sanctions
for example and say the West has done
this to you is that something that
protesters uh how do they respond to
that
well the regime will try currently the
regime strategies to claim that what
we're seeing on the streets is a quote
Zionist plot so it's reversing to its
old anti-semitic conspiracy theories but
look
if you look at the Iranian economy it's
very similar to that of Putin's regime
the Islam Republic is a oligarchic
kleptocratic corrupt regime to its core
um you know while the Iranian people
live under dire economic conditions and
also uh have a Hardline islamist
ideology imposed on them a small
percentage of the elites uh namely those
tied to the clergy and those tied to the
Revolutionary guards uh are controlling
the economy not only that their sons
their daughters their families are
living
lavish lifestyles in Western capitals
like London Paris New York uh so it's an
oligarchic system the arazade is the
so-called the what as we call them in
Farsi the noble born of the regime
Elites they live lavish Lifestyles while
the Iranian in the west while the
Iranian people uh live under dire
economic conditions not only that they
have a Hardline islamist order imposed
on them and I think look masamini's
death the 22 year old Iranian uh girl
who was murdered by the so-called
morality police of the regime her her
murder really gives exposure to what
life is really like in the Islamic
Republic this has been happening for 43
years so it's not about sanctions it's
not about U.S withdrew from the jcpoa
it's about living under an authoritarian
dictatorship that is corrupt to its core
but to the same extent I mean that
regime has created an economy that only
works for the elite as you have said to
what extent can the West if at all play
any role in alleviating furthering the
protest if it wants to whatever it sees
you mentioned the Putin regime or Putin
obviously sanctions against many of
those oligarchs what if anything uh what
responsive finish should the West have
in this case in Iran
that's really important I think well the
West has many policy leaders that it can
take against the Islamic Republic to
support the protesters and to limit the
Bloodshed on the street so impose real
consequences that will be felt by
harmonize regime one of the measures the
West can take is sanctioning and
targeting regime oligarchs living abroad
and their families blocking their assets
imposing travel bans a second measure
that the uh West can take is to impose
magnitsky sanctions against
irgc revolutionary guard commanders and
those involved in human rights abuses
and finally the West can take effective
measure against the Revolutionary guard
by listing it as a terrorist
organization the irgc is no different to
the likes of Isis or Al-Qaeda it
operates in no different way for example
it uses indoctrination to radicalize all
of its recruits in a Hardline islamist
ideology which by the way refers to
Iranians that are against the regime as
enemies and enemies of God and calls for
them to be tortured before their death
the irgc is also involved in Terrorist
operations globally it has been for the
past 43 years it should be prescribed as
a terrorist organization that's a really
important policy lever the West can take
all right um we'll have to leave it
there for now kazra Arabi at the Tony
Blake Institute in London thank you very
much
thank you very much